[Musik]
für fast zwei Jahrzehnte zwischen 1955
und 73 wuchs japans Wirtschaft mit einer
jährlichen Rate von sage und schreibe
neun Prozent und in den darauf folgenden
17 Jahren wuchs sie immerhin noch mit
über 4%. nach diesen Jahren der
Prosperität war das Land im Jahr 1989
wirtschaftlich enorm potent geworden in
kommen drei Jahrzehnten war Japan zu
einer gigantischen Industrie und
Finanzmarkt herangewachsen es war bei
weitem eines der reichsten Länder der
Welt außerdem waren japanische
multinationale Unternehmen zu den
wichtigsten technologischen Akteuren der
damaligen Zeit geworden Fernseher wie
die Recorder Kameras Videospiele
Konsolen die japanische Industrie
bestimmte technologische Agenda der Welt
und nicht nur das allein zwischen 1984
und 89 vervielfachte sich der Nicki
Index um mehr als das dreifacher werden
gleichzeitig die Immobilienpreise immer
neue Rekorde erklommen die Japaner waren
reich geworden und zwar so richtig reich
im Jahr 1990 Plaste diese Blase jedoch
plötzlich die japanische Wirtschaft
geriet in eine tiefe
wirtschaftsimmobilien und Finanzkrise
aus der sie bis heute nicht völlig
herausgekommen ist
[Musik]
und ja heute ist Japan immer noch ein
entwickeltes und wohlhabendes Land aber
die Dinge liegen ganz anders seh es euch
an
7 Februar 2023 Japan bestätigt
rekordinterventionen zur Stützung des
Yen Japan bestätigte nun dass es im
Oktober Interventionen in Rekord Höhe
angewiesenmarkt durchführte und 48
Milliarden US-Dollar verkauft hat um den
Yen zu stützen die quartalsdaten zeigen
dass ein steiler Fall ist ein 32 Jahres
tief vorne rund 152 Yen pro Dollar am 21
Oktober die Intervention an diesem Tag
ausgelöst hat eine weitere erfolgte am
24 Oktober die verdeckten Interventionen
erfolgten das heißt Eingriffe in den
Markt ohne Ankündigung nach dem Tokio am
22 September zum ersten Mal seit 24
Jahren für Dollars gekauft hatte dank
der Intervention der japanischen
Zentralbank konnte das Schlimmste noch
abgewendet werden damals verlor der Jen
fast 50% gegenüber seinem langjährigen
Kurs aber auch jetzt ist die japanische
Währung immerhin noch rund 25% weniger
wert ohne eine Perspektive auf eine
Rückkehr zu alten Standards in Sicht
wäre um euch eine Vorstellung davon zu
geben was eine derart lange Krise
wirklich bedeutet werden wir uns ansehen
was mit den Löhnen passiert ist heißt
das 21 Jahrhundert begann war der
Durchschnittslohn in den USA und Japan
ungefähr gleich hoch heute liegt der
Durchschnittslohn jedoch in den USA 2,5
Mal höher als der in Japan und
tatsächlich sind die japanischen Löhne
heute real das heißt inflationsbereinigt
niedriger als im Jahr 1997 mit anderen
Worten die Japaner verdienen heute
weniger als vor 25 Jahren eine ähnliche
Rückgang ist auch beim BIP zu beobachten
wenn z.B Japan und Deutschland 1990
unter Berücksichtigung des
Preisunterschied ungefähr das gleiche
pro Kopf hatten liegt das deutsche heute
um 35% höher eine weiteres Beispiel
Südkorea im Jahr 1990 lag die
südkoreanische Wirtschaft pro Kopf und
selbst nach Berücksichtigung des
Preisunterschieds auf einem Niveau des
etwa 40% des japanischen Sprache und
heute hat sie dieses bereits übertroffen
aber wie lässt sich diese
wirtschaftliche Niedergang erklären
warum hat sich japans Wirtschaft seit
mehr als 30 Jahren nicht mehr erholt
welche Entwicklungen können wir in den
kommenden Jahren erwarten und welche
Lehren können wir daraus für unsere
eigene Zukunft ziehen um all diese
Fragen zu beantworten werden wir uns
heute auf eine Reise ins Land der
aufgehenden Sonne begeben also
anschnallen und auf geht's
[Musik]
der Fleck auf der aufgehenden Sonne
bevor wir loslegen würde ich euch noch
gerne um zwei Dinge bitten falls euch
unsere Videos gefallen checkt doch
unbedingt auch unseren schwesterkanal
wieso alle economic.de ihr findet dort
spannende Videos darüber wie zum
Beispiel die Kriegswirtschaft der
Ukraine funktioniert oder ob uns eine
neue Bankenkrise wie 2008 droht wir
haben mit visuale economic.de bald die
100.000 Abo Marke erreicht hält uns doch
ein wenig beim endport und hinterlasst
dort ein kleines Abo mit Glöckchen ab
und zu brauchen wir auch ein wenig
Motivation von euch neben der
moralischen Unterstützung könnt ihr uns
natürlich auch gerne eine kleine
freiwillige Spende über den Link in der
Videobeschreibung zu kommen lassen das
macht die ganze Sache dann rund und wir
können unsere Miete bezahlen ich danke
euch für eure Aufmerksamkeit und
natürlich auch im Voraus für die
freundliche Unterstützung so und nun
lasst uns wieder zu unserem heutigen
Thema kommen Japan ist nach wie vor ein
relativ wohlhabendes Land und auch
weiterhin der größte Gläubiger der Welt
ganz genau entgegen der landläufigen
Meinung ist dies nicht China Japan hat
netto das heißt unter Berücksichtigung
der Differenz zwischen seine Schulden
und seinen Forderungen etwa 3,5
Billionen Dollar an Nettoinvestitionen
über die ganze Welt verteilt sind die
Japaner kontrollieren Fabriken Gebäude
Aktien Anleihen und alle Arten von
Finanzprodukten
Daten des Ministeriums für Wirtschaft
und Finanzen zeigen dass
japansdierungsreserven Ende Januar 2023
den dritten Monat in Folge auf 1,25
Billionen US-Dollar gestiegen sind dies
ist auf zündzahlungen für ausländische
Anleihen sinkende Zinsen und eine
schwächeren Dollar und gewinne beim Gold
zurückzuführen
die Devisen Reserven Japans stiegen im
April 2023 auf 1,265 Billionen US-Dollar
von 1,275 Billionen im März und
erreichten damit den zweiten Monaten
Folge den höchsten Stand seit 8 Monaten
aber trotzdem läuft es dort nicht gut in
der Praxis sind die Löhne seit Jahren
eingefroren die Staatsverschuldung
wächst schließlich unterjähren wird
immer instabiler nach Angaben der Bank
für internationalen Zahlungsausgleich
ist der denn derzeitig schwächste
Währung alle Industrieländer und in den
letzten Jahren ist seine Nieren gesunken
dadurch sind die Importe immer teurer
geworden und wenn die Japaner heutzutage
ins Ausland Reisende schütteln sie oft
genug den Kopf über die hohen Preise die
sie dort vorfinden wenn man zum Beispiel
den beliebten Big Mac Index der
Zeitschrift die Economist heranzieht
kostet ein Big Mac Burger in New York
70% mehr als in Tokio was ist also mit
der japanischen Wirtschaft los was ist
das für eine Krankheit an der sie leidet
wir wollen hier und heute vier
Hauptfaktoren hervorheben die
Hauptprobleme die den Niedergang des
Landes der aufgehenden Sonne erklären
erstens ist Japan aus arbeitsrechtlicher
Sicht im Wesentlichen noch dasselbe Land
wie vor 30 oder 40 Jahren man arbeitet
dort lange und unter strengen und
flexiblen Zeitplänen hinzu kommen dann
noch oft lange Fahrzeiten mit
öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln und nur
sehr wenig Urlaub das erklärt auch warum
Japan vielleicht das einzige Land der
Erde ist in dem es ein eigenes Wort für
das Phänomen Tod durch Überarbeitung
gibt karoshi dazu kommt zum Beispiel
noch das Beförderungen und
Gehaltsverbesserungen meist vom
Lebensalter oder der
Betriebszugehörigkeitsdauer und weniger
von individuellen Leistungen abhängen
das bedeutet unter anderem dass die
jüngere Bevölkerung weitgehend von den
führungs- und Entscheidungspositionen
ausgeschlossen ist mit anderen Worten an
der Spitze von Unternehmen und
Abteilungen stehen meisten Menschen die
mit neuen Technologien oder neuen
Markttrends wenig anfangen können und
diese Praxis wird auch dazu das
arbeitsblattwechsel sehr selten sind
wenn das Gehalt und die Position von der
Dauer der Betriebszugehörigkeit abhängen
ist klar dass man nicht ohne weiteres
Arbeitsblatt wechselt nur um wieder ganz
unten in der Hackordnung anzufangen
und die große Preisfrage ist nun ob es
nicht vielleicht möglich ist dass diese
stagnierende und rigide
Unternehmenskultur hinter einem der
großen Probleme steckt die dieses Land
mit sich herumschleppt nämlich der im
Vergleich verdammt miesen Produktivität
ja ganz genau die Japaner arbeiten zwar
viel und lange das wissen wir alle aber
im Gegensatz zu dem was man landläufig
glaubt sind sie dabei vergleichsweise
und produktiv so erreichte Output eines
Japaners pro Arbeitsstunde kommen 60%
des eines US-Amerikaners und ist mit
Abstand der niedrigste aller G7 Länder
seit 1990 ist diese Entwicklung sogar
deutlich schlechter als in einem Land
wie Spanien
darüber hinaus haben japanische
Unternehmen den letzten drei Jahrzehnten
viele ihre produktivsten Fabriken ist
Ausland verlagert und wisst ihr was das
Problem mit der niedrigen Produktivität
ist nicht nur dass sie das Einkommen
begrenzen an auch dass sie die Menschen
dazu zwingen viel länger zu arbeiten
deshalb hat Japan immer noch eine der
höchsten arbeitszeitquoten der Welt und
natürlich ist das in einem Land mit so
vielen demografischen Problemen in dem
es immer weniger Arbeitskräfte gibt eine
enorme menschliche Belastung statt sich
persönlich zu entfalten seinem Partner
zu widmen oder eine Familie zu planen
hocken die meisten Japaner einfach und
produktiv auf der Arbeit herum und
wundern sich dann dass sie keine Kinder
bekommen und damit werden wir auch schon
beim zweiten großen Problem dass wir uns
rot anstreichen können der Demografie
Japan ist das am stärksten über Alter
der Land der Welt seit 2011 schrumpft
die Bevölkerung von Jahr zu Jahr und im
Jahr 2.36 werden die über 65-Jährigen
voraussichtlich fast 35% der Bevölkerung
ausmachen
damit nicht genug den Prognosen zufolge
wird dieses Land in etwas mehr als 40
Jahren mehr als 30% seiner Einwohner
verloren haben das heißt die japanische
Bevölkerung wird von 126 Millionen im
Jahr 2020 auf knapp über 87 Millionen im
Jahr 2065 schrumpfen und das meine
Lieben Zuschauer stellt einen
demografischen Rückgang da wie es ihn in
der Geschichte der Menschheit noch nicht
gegeben hat eine derart beispiellose
Entwicklung hat natürlich auch starke
Auswirkungen auf die Wirtschaft weniger
Bevölkerung und eine ältere Bevölkerung
bedeuten weniger verfügbare
Arbeitskräfte weniger Konsum weniger
Ersparnisse und stark erhöhte
Sozialausgaben insbesondere im Bereich
der Renten und Gesundheitsversorgung
aber zu diesem Thema haben wir schon mal
ein eigenes Video gemacht ich werde es
euch verlinken an dritter Stelle stehen
dann die Verbindungen mit der Außenwelt
[Musik]
man weckt ja normalerweise das Japan
eine sehr weltoffene und globalisierte
Wirtschaft hat aber die Realität sieht
ganz anders aus Japan war und ist immer
noch in allen Bereichen eine relativ
verschlossenes Land und das hat
gravierende austergrund denn wenn die
Bevölkerung eures Landes schrumpft
kannte Export die beste Alternative sein
um das Produktionsniveau aufrecht zu
erhalten wenn weniger Menschen im Inland
Waren und Dienstleistungen kaufen können
ist es natürlich logisch dass man sich
um Kunden im Ausland bemüht oder nicht
Deutschland beispielsweise tut genau das
Japan hingegen ist eines der
Industrieländer in den Exporte die
geringste wirtschaftliche Präsenz haben
ja wir müssen an dieser Stelle endlich
mit dem Klischee aufräumen dass die
Japaner ihren Lebensunterhalt
hauptsächlich damit verdienen Dinge an
den Rest der Welt zu verschenken denn
das stimmt einfach nicht tatsächlich
haben ist japanische Unternehmen trotz
eines eindeutig stark nierenden
regionalen Märkte schwer ihre Waren im
Ausland zu etablieren und abzusetzen ihr
glaubt nicht dann seht euch mal
folgendes an
der Anteil der Exporte an der Wirtschaft
ist im internationalen Vergleich einer
der kleinsten und es geht hier nicht nur
um den Handel wie wir euch bereits in
einem früheren Video gezeigt haben dass
sie wir verlinken werde ist Japan auch
eines der Länder mit den niedrigsten
ausländischen Direktinvestitionen der
Welt sie betragen nur etwas mehr als 4%
des BIP und wisst ihr wo der
Durchschnitt außer der schon direkt
Investition in der Industrieländer liegt
bei nicht weniger als
44%. das sind stattliche 11 mal mehr und
das ist natürlich ein weiterer
gewichtiger Faktor der die Produktivität
den Wettbewerb und die Innovation
einschränkt gleichzeitig ist Japan aber
auch das Industrieland mit den meisten
einwanderungsbeschränkungen auf der Welt
nur 2,3% japanischen Bevölkerung sind im
Ausland geboren
Studie Japan wird bis 2040 viermal so
viele ausländische Arbeitskräfte
brauchen laut einer Studie wird Japan im
Jahr 2040 6,74 Millionen ausländische
Arbeitskräfte benötigen etwa viermal so
viele wie heute um das von der Regierung
angestrebte Wirtschaftswachstum zu
erreichen das Team analysierte auch die
demografischen Daten und das
Wirtschaftswachstum von 13 asiatischen
Ländern darunter China und Vietnam aus
denen in der Vergangenheit ausländische
Arbeitskräfte nach Japan gekommen sind
sowie die durchschnittlich
Aufenthaltsdauer dieser Arbeitskräfte in
Japan das Team kannst du dem Schluss
dass das erwartete Wirtschaftswachstum
oder die singenden Geburtenraten in
diesen Ländern den internationalen
Wettbewerb um ausländische Arbeitskräfte
in Zukunft wahrscheinlich verschaffen
werden ob in Bezug auf Handel
Investitionen oder Einwanderung dieses
Land ist wahrscheinlich das isolierteste
unter den entwickelten Volkswirtschaften
in gewisser Weise ist Japan also nicht
nur geographisch eine Insel sondern auch
wirtschaftlich und das stellt natürlich
ein gigantisches Problem da
[Musik]
aber kommen wir zum vierten und letzten
großen Punkt denn als wäre das alles
nicht schon genug ist das Gerüste
Problem Japans eigentlich das ist seit
30 Jahren dieselbe Politik verfolgt eine
Politik die im Wesentlichen auf zwei
Ideen beruht mehr geldpolitische und
mehr steuerliche Anreize so ist die
japanische Zentralbank derzeit die
einzige Zentralbank der Welt die die
Zinsen auf extrem niedrigen Niveau hält
das erklärt größtenteils im Kurs dass
das Handy mit zu Beginn des Videos
gesehen haben kurz danach versuchte die
japanische Zentralbank zwar mit
moderaten sind Erhöhung dem etwas
entgegen zu steuern doch inzwischen ist
man von diesem Kurs schon wieder
abgekommen auf der anderen Seite hat die
Regierung bei dem Versuch der Krise zu
entkommen die höchste bruttoverschuldung
der Welt angehäuft wir sprechen hier von
einer Staatsverschuldung die mehr als
230% des BIP entspricht mehr dazu und
wieso Japan unter diesen Bedingungen
nicht eigentlich sofort pleite geht
erklären wir euch auf unserem
schwesterkanal visualökonomic ich werde
euch das entsprechende Video verlinken
also schaut es euch nachher unbedingt an
denn auch wenn Japan nicht sofort pleite
geht auf jeden Fall steht fest dass der
japanische Staat ja für Jahr öffentliche
Defizite als gebe es kein Morgen klingt
nach einem Teufelskreis nicht wahr und
gibt es dann überhaupt noch Hoffnung nun
haltet euch fest denn die gibt es
tatsächlich Wetten immer mehr Analysten
darauf das ist mit Japan langfristig
finanziell wieder bergauf gehen könnte
und warum nun das schauen wir uns jetzt
noch an
[Musik]
ein Land im Sonderangebot
in den letzten 30 Jahren hatte
japanische Aktienmärkte so schlecht
performt wie kaum ein anderer in der
entwickelten Welt wenn man dazu noch den
Wertverlust der Sinn mitrechnet haben
wir es mit einem der billigsten
Aktienmärkte der gesamten entwickelten
Welt zu tun an der Tokioter Börse werden
viele Unternehmen bereits zu einem Preis
gehandelt der kaum höher liegt als die
angesammelten Barmittel in ihrem
Bilanzen und genau deshalb behaupten
viele Analysten dass der Abschlag
allmählich so groß wird dass das Land zu
einer echten Chance für Anleger werden
könnte vor allem auch weil das Land
versucht viele seine Probleme zu lösen
Japans perfekte wirtschaftswelle kommt
gut in Schwung die japanische Wirtschaft
boomt die Löhne steigen der Aktienmarkt
ist so hoch wie seit drei Jahrzehnten
nicht mehr und die Aussichten sind so
positiv wie seit Jahren nicht mehr
Japans Wirtschaftswachstum im ersten
Quartal war stärker als produziert
obwohl seine traditionell starken
Exporte das Wachstum in den drei Monaten
geschmälert haben im Zuge der früher als
Lohn Offensive sind die Löhne in vielen
Fällen um zwei bis vier Prozent
gestiegen und Millionen von
Arbeitnehmern konnten zum ersten Mal
seit mehr als einem Jahr erwähnt kleine
reale Einkommenszuwächse verzeichnen
Kenji aber Stratege bei diversecurities
sagte dass die starke ausländische
Nachfrage nach japanischen Aktien seit
April durch den vorstoße Tokioter Börse
für bessere Corporate Governance
angetrieben wurde japans Wirtschaft
erholt sich endlich angeführt von der
Inlandsnachfrage sagte hideo kumano
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler andaligi life
Research Institute wenn das Wachstum im
zweiten Quartal über einen Prozent
bleibt bedeutet das dass wir uns auf ein
Umfeld zu bewegen indem die Unternehmen
die Löhne im nächsten Jahr erneut
anheben können so dass sich die
japanische Regierung etwa für
Freihandelsabkommen ein und ist sogar
federführend beim cppp einem der
wichtigsten Freihandelsabkommen weltweit
und bei diesem wollen wirklich alle
mitmachen vom Vereinigten Königreich bis
zur Volksrepublik China und gerade Japan
ist es das hier die entscheidenden Fäden
in der Hand hält
[Musik]
außerdem hat die Regierung geschida die
wir euch bereits in einem früheren Video
dass ich euch verlinken werde berichtet
haben vor kurzem einen Plan zur
Wiederbelebung der Kernenergie
vorangetrieben um große Mengen an
Energie und billigen Wasserstoff zu
gewinnen und das ist nicht zu
unterschätzen denn gerade die
Energierechnung war als die in den
letzten Jahren eines der großen Probleme
des Landes darstellte die Regierung
fördert auch die Verbesserung der
Corporate Governance in Unternehmen die
Integration von Frauen in die Berufswelt
und erleichtert die Ansiedlung
ausländische Investoren und Einwanderer
und wenn wir zu all dem noch die
Tatsache hinzurechnen dass das Land
durch sinkende Löhne und Preise sehr
wettbewerbsfähig geworden ist und sich
in einer der am schnellsten wachsen
Regionen der Welt befindet dann sollte
das Potenzial neponds sowohl offenkundig
sein gut man kann nun einwenden dass man
all das auch schon vor zehn Jahren hätte
sagen können nur viel gebracht hat es
bisher scheinbar noch nicht neu
hinzukommen sollen noch geschieht das
Fantasien von einer neuen Formulierung
des japanischen Kapitalismus danach soll
die Wirtschaft mit noch mehr
öffentlichen Ausgaben und mehr
Interventionismus gedruckt werden dazu
fordert er zusammen mit der Zentralbank
noch kräftigere Erhöhungen der Gehälter
das ist eine Art von Nachfragepolitik
welche in Japan schon seit zehn Jahren
nicht gut funktioniert unserer Meinung
nach kann das nicht gut enden aber es
stimmt schon das Japan im Grunde
genommen sehr billig ist woraus sich in
Zukunft noch Chancen ergeben könnten und
deswegen seid ihr es erstmal ihr an der
Reihe glaubt ihr das Japan es schaffen
wird sondern nicht enden wollen den
Krise zu entkommen und könnte es am Ende
doch zu einer investitionsgelegenheit
werden was würdet ihr anstelle geschieht
das tun um japans Wirtschaft
wiederzubeleben und zu guter Letzt
würdet ihr in den japanischen Markt
investieren wollen wie immer sind auf
eure Diskussion zu diesem Thema schon
mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass euch
dieses Video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht etwas dabei gelernt habt
falls ja gibt uns ein Like falls mit
euren Freunden und vergesst nicht das
Abo mit glücklich und keines unserer
Videos mehr zu verpassen natürlich
freuen wir uns auch jederzeit über eine
Spende von euch interessiert dieses
Projekt weiterzuführen den Link dazu
findet ihr in der Beschreibung unter dem
Video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]